i ragazzi sperimentano video sono cosa
stai facendo
siamo tornati su il playstation world e
oggi visto che c'è il mio papà a casa
mia mi faccio provare il playstation
move sei pronto
bravo sei già tutto bravo benigni mezzo
carico di alza un braccio ora prima di
adesso provato ok si sentiva sopra
perché lo saprà bravissimo grandissimo
adesso praticamente vedete entri in un
ufficio che li fa finta di lavorare in
ufficio o uguale a tutti i giorni
contati diventano sei mancato si veda
alla voce due computer che mi sposto
[Musica]
niente ragazzi ho capito dalle più breve
uguale io di fare il login e col mouse
però noi premi tipo qualsiasi cosa vedi
un qualsiasi cosa che vuoi e propria non
c'è niente per chi la sorella nella
fotocopiatrice bravo bravissimo
fotocopia ma adesso il pittore del sito
ranniko bellissima poi alla segretaria
bona mettila sul lettino allevati che
possa tirare il freno questo è bello non
l'ho ancora fatto che sul mio canale se
il primo a farlo praticamente devi
aggiustare la macchina non so cosa devi
fare se non lo sto facendo io lo faccio
anch'io con la prima volta mi arriva la
macchina gira pesante
adesso ingrediente che figata
allora devi aggiustare la macchina non
mi chiedere perché non ti sto dare
consigli non solo anche come è fatta la
macchina apri apri famiglia spezzata
quale la testata della marina riusciti
la capocciata lordi come tu sei più
esperto di me nella macchina adesso
guarda guardava antigua davanti e mi
dici pezzi della macchina tutti testata
l'olio è quella destra questo se il
flusso canalizzatore è una patata papa
filtro questo filtro cambiamo fitto dove
si ma non su libertà è come di chi in
futuro dice ti dice devi mettere
sinistra di mettere quel coso nero
dentro e cosa arancione quindi in regia
dell'essere prendi un rosanero l'olio
l'olio di origano quello non quello col
gas per chi dentro tutto febbraio
dobbiamo fare appelli di fare cosa
palazzo faccia revisori
ecco adesso se tu guardi girate sinistra
c'è scritto griffata la patata la
cambiamenti le batterie modo che tali la
patata e metti su questi c'è anche stage
c'è stage di de colo stage the core
hanno sbagliato becchi un qualcos'altro
tipo
scegli una di quelle una di quelle non è
così di mezzo è dura metti metti lì
aspetto 3.500 dollari abbiamo noi di big
money dargliela nel culo ex no al tipo
di daniela tipo lui che sgancia i nonni
allora tutti potessero adesso cominciano
in faccia al board cliente tempo stage
inedita tante cose questa scena mi piace
andare una banana perché ha soste di
starci c'è una banana
nola latina non credo che la mattina
della ii papa prefetto ok stacca 120
l'altro l'ex mac devi girare la
manovella sulla f back les fleurs des
quelle proteste front ha sempre più
difficile la quale l'ex front da
electron trasporta le boe che sotto
leggi poiché beh apposta benzina benzina
metti metti metti testaccio diventa il
carcere non c'è scritto stato un suk
stage questa qua o steinheim internet il
perfetto quello dentro
dentro la mattina lo zucchero per
fondere il motore fase vista che chiude
2 farò ma special pack supporto a di
rifarne due perché questo c'è laico
bomber 1 nostra sorella 3.767 di che mi
devo aprire uno che cinque che mettono a
fare i clienti da buttare la macchina ha
scritto officina non miracoli
non lo so c'è un fiore perché c'è il
falso del tronto così no no no non si fa
questa ragione infatti non questo non
vuole fare non posso mettere su youtube
questi mtv mtv mtv ha buttato dentro
league ma no dentro dentro dentro dentro
anche così perfette ora che
divertentissimo provoca la sua
segreteria dovrebbe essere sì mondo di
giusta ce l'hai a destra destra destra
destra quello col rosso con bassi basso
queste sì non erano giuste che cazzo
bastò un motivo premio che tira qualcosa
dietro l'altra mano
eccoli ecco dice lei prendi tra gli
diceva no questa se uno se l'aspetta
mette dentro congelati così ma chi sei
break aspetta aspetta questo ha comprato
po come chi passa l'idea roma che non ha
comprata me di là dentro
ok metti altra roba tipo il vaso di
fiori
ecco basta il pane è già perché a volte
servire a tirare la leva per i soldi
passano i soldi a quelle gattini c
rigore a cinque cerchi esperto di merda
ma non colpito quel pane di giro in giro
di così vaste casi lui no esatto
ed ecco che promette del mondo di sci
tocca a me da allora la chance play non
ho capito cosa vuole su garage che cadde
su sugar rush su deve essere zucchero e
la grana e non lo so non sono sicuro sia
questo possono figlio sono fin troppi
se l'è preso funzionerà questo non ho
capito allora questo alla fine navas
ma il culo tetto i conti linee non in
chiama effetti cosa vuoi desk complete
grazie fortissimo adesso spetta a voi
superamenti ovunque su come fatto ti
spari faccia guida di stimolo guarda a
prato passano le macchine di fuori della
serie butta qualcosa non molta meno del
partito dove esatte che cosa vuol
interrogato trovato pregiati oggi pure
mi sono messo bene attivo come shock
mascella q con i soli dentro libero io
devo fare a django cos'è sta roba
jumbo saiter abelin chiaf in issimo
avere bastava andava bene così elio io a
posto finito il mio turno
datemi money che vado a casa ma lei
ragazzi dire che fosse concludere quindi
di oggi è stato alquanto strano tre
reati spero che vi sia piaciuto
ringrazio mio papa per aver partecipato
a questo video bello e di avermi
insegnato come si cambia il filtro della
macchina adesso mi manca ma la macchina
video che i ragazzi
al momento mi piace anche a me ne
diventi mai come di rito la tradizione
senza vestiti siete dici mi chiamo
proseguito dio grazie che l'ho preso al
volo dai ragazzi